vous savez ce qui va se passer eh bien
nous allons bientôt manquer de l'eau
et c'est pourquoi je bois devant vous un
verre d'eau précieuse puisque avant la
fin du siècle si nous continuons un tel
débordement elle moquera merci mes amis
de
la sécheresse dure depuis trois ou
quatre ans elle revient une fois que les
60 ans mais auparavant elle portait sur
des pays moins peuplés
maintenant avec la la densité de la
population ne peut plus faire autant de
jachère qu autrefois l'humus ne se
reconstitue plus est par conséquent
l'érosion attaque les éléments fin du
sol limo et le sable fin
[Musique]
nous manqueront d'eau en l'an 2050 du
fait de l'augmentation constante d
utilisation urbaine par conséquent il
faudrait prévoir que la population du
monde serait raisonnable d'arrêter son
explosion et les développements
industriels développement urbain
spécialement n'est pas sans conséquences
graves sur l'avenir du monde
il ya le problème des déchets
radioactifs et de la pollution thermique
des rivières ou des mères au bord
desquels on installe les centrales
atomiques
devient comique c'est l'air que nous
respirons c'est l'eau de nos rivières
qui sert aussi bien à la vue de tous les
jours c'est l'eau potable dont nous
avons besoin c'est l'eau pure dans nos
usines ont besoin c'est non seulement
l'activité écologique la vie biologique
est menacé c'est toute l'activité
économique
si nous continuons notre développement
acharné notre pillage du tiers-monde
notre croissance sauvage et bien c'est
l'effondrement total de notre
civilisation avant la fin de ce siècle
le jeu en
vaudra sly contre autoroutes ils ont des
chances de préserver ce qui pourra
l'être de moins
je ne suis pas un candidat doux rêveur
j'ai 45 ans travaille agronomique sur le
terrain où 45 ans de travail
d'enseignement surtout à l'institut
national agronomique de paris donc dire
que je suis un candidat pas sérieux
c'est tout de même s'avancer un peu vite
quand on va étudier les problèmes au
village avec les paysans avec les
agriculteurs on doit être sérieux
[Musique]